foreign
so I'm going to talk about attention
today and uh
I know what you're thinking if you oh
this is going to be about Tick Tock and
Twitter and how social media is terrible
for us uh so no it's not gonna be about
that
social media is terrible for us but it's
not going to be about that uh it's gonna
be a little more complicated
and I want to I want to start by just uh
telling a little bit about what kind of
uh approach I have towards explaining
things about the mind so I'm a
philosopher this affiliation hides
whether I'm really a philosopher or a
psychologist but I am a philosopher
however I'm a little different in terms
of my philosophical methodology than uh
than many other philosophers so the
traditional way in which philosophers
used to explain things is by just
consistently ignoring the Sciences so
just no communication whatsoever between
the sciences and philosophy so more
recently people have been uh saying
philosophers have been paying more
attention to uh to what's going on in
the Sciences so the dream is to give
philosophical theories that are informed
by The Sciences but they're also
relevant to the Sciences so you might
think that sounds nice about how do you
do that and one way in which it can work
very nicely is a philosophy brings
together two different sub-disciplines
scientific sub-disciplines because
scientists are busy people look at them
busy with a little pipette
um but what but but philosophers do they
have anything they have time so we can
actually
read read up on all of the these
disciplines and bring them into Co into
somehow dialogue with each other and
that's exactly what I'm trying to do in
this project uh where um where I'm
trying to combine social psychology
perceptual psychology
and Neuroscience so this is this is kind
of a plan of the talk I'm gonna talk
about three things
first thing I want to convince you of is
that attention the way you allocate your
attention can radically change the way
you see the world so we should really be
very concerned about how we're attending
and what we're attending to the second
claim is probably uh the least
controversial so attention is in short
supply these days and that is that very
heavily influences our quality of life
and the third thing is to try to
understand what's the main reason for
this unfortunate fact that attention is
in short supply and again it's not what
you think it's not about social media
it's about something else
God can you feel the tension if it's
all right so do you remember this
you do
it was like eight years ago
and also England didn't do so well
so that's you know that was the logo of
the World Cup and you know this was the
shape is supposed to be the World Cup
trophy the colors are the Brazilian
national colors but uh look at this
face bomb
if you'll get it again it's very
difficult not to see
not to see it as a face bomb so what's
happening here is that you're attending
to different aspects of the picture and
that radically changes the quality of
your experience
here maybe not for the better although
I'm not sure that it was really a good
image to begin with but it can make a
very important positive difference as
well so this picture this painting I can
tell you that it's an early painting by
Paul clay it's from 1915. uh what I what
I um and it's you know you either like
it or you don't like it what I'm going
to tell you now is what the title of the
uh of the painting and it's not Untitled
like many other painting in that period
but it's green X above left
and look at it again
how many of you have seen the how many
of you've noticed noticed the the green
act really before really [ __ ]
so in this case uh this was a positive
difference right so so maybe before you
thought that uh maybe the the the
picture the the composition doesn't
really hang together but once you're
attending to the green ax above left
it's all somehow makes sense but
allocational retention can make a
negative difference as well so how many
of you have seen Goldfinger
then you probably have noticed this
interesting similarity
um which is very pretty disconcerting
especially the given The Narrative of
Goldfinger but all right
now uh so this is about the allocation
of attention in uh then then it makes a
negative difference I'm guessing
but it's also it's very important that
that just how you're attending to which
which features of something you're
attending to is very much very heavily
dependent on your background assumptions
this is a um a little metal that people
in the Salomon Islands in Polynesia wear
and if you look at it with your
background knowledge you probably see it
as a nice abstract pattern but in fact
in that Island it's all about fishing
right it's a small island basically all
the food that they get to eat is fish
and these apparently these little little
figures they depict fish dolphins of
some kind and this shape
depicts the frigate bird that preys on
fish and it's very useful to know where
the fish are so once you know this once
you're paying attention to that again
that's going to be a very different kind
of experience so so far I talked about
the difference it makes
uh what it is what it is that you're
attending to and I can see that I
completely lost everyone because I
um but but what I want to say is that it
also makes a huge difference about not
just what you're attending to but how
you're attending to to something and
here I want to I want to make this
distinction between focused and
distributed attention it's not really my
distinction it's a it's a
well-established distinction in vision
science
so so this is a somewhat famous study
about how experts and novice uh novices
in terms of art school training look at
the same painting if you're a novice you
you tend to have focused attention to
the kind of the focal object uh and if
you're if you're a uh if you have some
kind of article training then you're
gonna have a more distributed attention
so this
this convince you that attention has a
big impact on the quality of her
experience
why is this especially important for us
it's especially important for us because
the way you exercise your attention has
a huge makes a huge difference in just
your general quality of life
and there's a really interesting set of
results about the connection between
um between attention and addiction and
the surest sign of addiction
is about is about the way you're
exercising your attention so if you're
addicted to some things for example a
gambling addiction people with the
gambling addiction they their attention
is captured very quickly by any kind of
stimulus that's related to gambling and
they can't really detach that attention
from the gambling so it seems like one
thing that's happening in addiction
cases is some kind of really close
capture of the of the of the attention
so the general line I wanna I wanna take
here is that too much focused attention
is just bad for you what we really need
is some kind of distributed open-ended
attention freely attending to things not
having our attention drawn to certain
predetermined things because that does
not contribute to our general uh
well-being and the reason why it's
difficult to do is because attention is
a is in short supply attention is a is a
limited quality so if you're if you're
turning to one thing then you're not
going to be able to to attend to another
thing and there's a huge amount of
perceptual psychological results about
how uh attention has a certain you know
it's like a is a limited amount of
butter that you can spread
evenly on a larger step but there's just
not much that you can spread spread
around so
um
it's in short short supply and if it's
taken up by certain mental processes
there's not going to be enough for other
Mentor processes and what I want to say
is that the main reason why we are in
this kind of predicament in terms of
attention is not really social media
it's about fragmentation it's about
fragmented Minds I'm going to talk about
how and why our mind is fragmented so
the first thing I want to say is that
the mind can be more or less fragmented
anyone's mind can be more or less
fragmented by which I just say that the
information travels more or less freely
between different parts of the mind so
sometimes what goes on in one part of
the Mind
has no impact on what goes on in other
parts of the mind is this a familiar
phenomenon for some of you so
neuroscientists are very much interested
in this thing called functional
connectivity so there's anatomical
connectivity which is a very simple
thing to measure it's just how much
neural connections are there between two
brain regions functional connectivity is
a much more interesting concept and it's
about how the activation of one brain
region automatically triggers the
activation of another brain region so
for example here are two uh two brain
regions the green and the blue and they
seem to really very uh very closely
related so it seems like there's a very
high degree of functional connectivity
between the two things
now you can kind of
average the local this kind of this
local connectivity local functional
connectivity between any given brain
regions and if you average them then you
get a certain value for any individual
mind and that is the uh what is
sometimes called the global functional
connectivity of a brain and that is a
very good indication of fragmentation so
the more Global connectivity you have
the less fragmented your mind is because
the more Global connective to have the
more freely information can travel from
one part of the world to your mind to
the other and there's a lot of really
interesting uh results here so This
Global connectivity is low in
schizophrenia patients so the
schizophrenia patient's mind is more
fragmented it also decreases with age so
the older you get the more fragmented
your mind gets sorry to break that all
right so let's see um so not all not all
fragmentation is all bad I'm gonna try
to zero in on the kind of fragmentation
the form of fragmentation that is not
good for you to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas